[Musique]
la campagne électorale n'est pas
commencé mais depuis des mois est
possible d'ignorer des signes d'une
tension le climat de confrontation et
les dérapages
vous n'avez pas votre place démissionner
nous en avons assez de la merde de
droite des conservateurs je donnerais 50
dollars quand il s'occupera la bave et
on lèvera sont pas cool est des dessus
de la tête
les messages haineux sur les médias
sociaux c'est le quotidien du chef
néo-démocrate des menaces de mort il en
a reçu plusieurs est souvent la violence
s'exprime ouvertement je manque les mots
pour le décrire un phénomène grandissant
qui l'inquiète
je ne pense pas de ma sécurité mais j'ai
peur pour les autres candidats les
autres candidates
il ya un élément de sexisme dans la
critique que j'ai foi en particulier de
la droite la ministre de l'environnement
est une cible de choix ces jours ci
alors c'est horrible c'est pas seulement
horrible pour moi parce que moi j'ai des
enfants c'est trois enfants ça les
militants de la droite
elle avait déjà surnommée la barbie du
climat les attaques se sont intensifiées
en plein débat sur la tarification du
carbone
il ya des gens qui détient
vraiment action sur les changements
climatiques mais aussi des traces les
femmes alors s'habiller ou vraiment
étrange mais il ya une connexion vous
êtes malhonnête et véreuses vous avez
été élu comme libéral porte comme
conservatrice espace de lune
je dois quitter les banquettes du
gouvernement biyouna à l'esl aig a reçu
son lot d'injures après avoir traversé
la chambre pour rejoindre les
conservateurs l'automne dernier elle a
pensé tout abandonner c'est sa famille
qui l'a convaincu de rester
ça c'est le monde maintenant convives ce
sociologue étudie les comportements en
ligne des débats politiques dans les
sociétés occidentales à la montée des
extrêmes un peu partout il prédit des
élections agité l'automne prochain une
campagne le vivre ensemble sera malmené
il y a les citoyens derrière leurs
claviers
les opinions exprimées en un clic mais
les politiciens contribue-t-il eux mêmes
au problème
à ottawa on sent le clivage les débats
sont acrimonieux et peu nuancé surtout
lorsqu'ils touchent l'environnement
l'immigration par exemple
[Applaudissements]
x
nous libéral inclut les francophones
bilingues la femme déjà ne pas tout le
monde du président se serait déporté sur
la chatte donc blâme les réfugiés on
blâme les médiations ont utilisé même
langage ont créé cette terrain et on
augmente sept terrains des fertile
plaindre la classe politique elle-même
doit faire un examen de conscience quoi
cette députée conservatrice
le comportement doit changer c'est à
nous de donner l'exemple mais il ya
aussi la responsabilité des géants comme
facebook et twitter la ministre mais qui
n'a quoi que ces entreprises ont
l'obligation d'agir et déjà une
conversation avec une des entreprises et
j'ai dit qu'est ce que vous allez faire
et m'ont dit monsieur vous avez quelque
chose qui vous dérange demandez-nous
twitter justin trudeau a justement
promis une nouvelle charte numérique
pour lutter contre la propagation d
idéologie violente et haineuse en ligne
il promet de nouvelles obligations et
des sanctions pour les géants du web
pour les forcer à mieux filtrer leur
contenu au delà des règles une réflexion
de société s'impose quoi cet expert
j'espère que c'est le début d'une prise
conscience
l'idée ce qui va retrouver l'art de
dialoguer ensemble
il est là tout le défi retrouver un
débat respectueux dans un monde d'idées
par les émotions en instantané une
jungle en manque de balises